[Music]
[Music]
so tim
sourdough very fashionable everyone
loves it what makes a perfect starter
and what's the best way to look after it
and get it going you start off with some
flour
preferably if you can get it some sort
of unbleached flour so it's still got
some natural yeasts in it you add
an equal amount of water to that and you
leave it standing around you can speed
that process up by putting in a handful
of dried fruit
and it will collect the yeasts in the
air and start a sourdough culture moving
and after a couple of days it will start
to bubble a little bit and that's your
starting point
you feed it with an equal amount of
flour and water each time i want to feed
it i
pour away most of it 50 to 100 grams
left in the bottom
and then to that i add roughly 200 grams
of flour and 200 grams of water
every time i feed it and it's one of
those things that works really well if
you've been doing it
all your life which i i haven't been
doing i've had mixed results with my
starters
there's this one which was last fed
about two days ago i think
three days ago which i almost poured on
the laptop in fact i did just pour on
the laptop
that's a good start that's the one
that's been fed more recently
it's actually been bubbling over like a
magic potion the simplest thing that we
could do with it i thought would be
pizzas takes away all the fuss about
trying to to shape the loaf which is so
complicated
so get yourself a bowl i'm going to use
a mixture of strong flour and plain
flour it ran out everywhere
that went straight to the bakery they
only sell it in 16 kilo sacks
so i've been distributing it to all of
my friends and family anyone who needs
it how much you pay for it 15
pounds for 16 kilos so that's a really
really decent generous baker you've got
there which tries to sell it to you for
60 quid you probably could sell it for
60 quid at the moment we'll put in 150
of
strong flour 150 of plain 10 grams of
salt
50 grams of olive oil pour in 200 grams
of your starter you say
pour i wonder where the spoon might
spoon is fine well
it's looking alive which of course it is
so what should i take it up to
my mouth is terrible zero witch every
time oh god i haven't done that so you'd
have been on 360.
okay so i need to get it up to four
sixty five sixty
and the last thing you're gonna need is
gonna be 150 grams of water
zero every time of course you should do
that
[Music]
use a fork or something like that to
just really really loosely mix that
together
and then let it sit for about half an
hour just knead it until it's you know
good and good in the last night we can
come back to it later
[Music]
take your clove of garlic cut it across
the middle all the garlicky bits out of
the top and put them straight into the
bottom of your roasting tin
pour in two cans of tomato sauce you add
pepper and salt to that
and a squid of olive oil just to give it
a really loose stir
my grandad used to always put sugar in
his tomato sauce where do you stand on
that
you shouldn't need it with decent
tomatoes his tomato sauce was great what
you can do
is a shot of balsamic vinegar it also
adds a little bit of sour
then just chuck the lot in the oven
that's so simple i don't think i'm ever
going to make a tomato sauce on the hob
again that's it
[Music]
mine looks a little black around the
edges should i be worried about that
that's fine
scrape it in all of your garlic should
have gone completely flat so you should
be able to do this by mashing with a
spoon
this sauce is the absolute new york
pizzeria it's again american standard
because you can do it really really
quickly by putting this the sauce
ingredients in the pizza oven
it's a good old-school sort of catering
industry trick
that's it that's the sauce all of our
sourdough cultures are different so they
work at different rates
so the rule that we tend to use is has
it doubled in size
now once yours has doubled in size it's
done its thing and then you need to
cut it into four pieces and form each of
those pieces into a neat ball
you don't have to worry about keeping
everything tight and neat and doing the
shaping bit
just make them roughly into balls and
stack them up in a tray and put that
tray
in the fridge in the industry we call
this retarding we're going to [ __ ] the
dough overnight
and that's going to give it a time to
develop better flavors
[Music]
put some flour on the table pick up one
of your holes place it in the middle of
the flour
allow it to use its own weight to kind
of stretch out
by passing it from finger to finger and
as soon as you start to get a sort of
round shape
put it down on the flower pull it out
sideways with your fingers
you've got it that's good that's really
good it doesn't take much more than that
now if you were
an italian you'd now throw it up in the
air and catch it if you get a tear in it
you can squeeze it closed have you got a
peel a peel one of those things for
shooting a pizza onto a pizza stone
oh yeah yeah big shovel thing go get
your big shovel thing it's
way too big for our kitchen it's
absolutely ridiculous wait until you see
this perfect
that's a commercial one yes i'm using
circular tin tray put some flour on the
peel and then put the pizza dough on top
of it
and then sort of shovel it about just to
make sure that it moves
on the peel so i've got a pita stone
which of course
heats the pizza up to a much higher
temperature than my oven would do
otherwise
can you do these kind of pizzas just in
a regular oven
totally the thinner the steel tray you
use if you're putting it on an oven tray
the better because that will heat
through quicker continuing to stretch it
just a little bit
around the outside leaving a slightly
raised crust
and now mine's perfectly circular and
i'm very happy with it don't put
heavy downward pressure on it because
that way you'll probably tear the base
which you don't want to do
use a maximum of two tablespoons full
now sprinkle black pepper on top
cheap stick block mozzarella that seems
a bit difficult to get at the moment so
i got this off-brand barata
tear it into little pieces and drop them
quite carefully i've got some
particularly fine olive oil floating
about a little squirt of that on top of
it a fresh basil leaf go on top there as
well let's give it a little shovel
it's moving do not take it to the oven
until you're absolutely positive you can
shoot it off
yeah it almost slid off the shovel okay
let's put them in the oven
oh there she goes yeah that shouldn't
take too long right five minutes or
something
it's that tim where do you stand on
pizza toppings i always got the sense
that the purest
think just cheese and tomato is it's how
you judge
whether a pizza is a really good quality
i think now we're in lockdown we need to
stop being so damn judgmental
there's a lot to be said for a good
neapolitan pizza which is very pure
close to what we're making here
but and if you tell anybody i've said
this i will come to your house and i
will kill you
and all those you love but i like ham
and pineapple it
scandal sorry my daughter's just asked
if she should be adopted
okay let's do it
oh mate that's really good i love your
edges i'm just gonna lift mine up very
nice
it's cute what do you reckon
that's pretty good you should be able to
be able to think now of of tweaks you
could do to that is sourdough goes so
well with blue cheese
some slices of pear you don't have to
stick to just italian lama [ __ ]
it's a turkish flatbread make the bed
the base that same way put olive oil all
over it and then you crumble
seasoned ground lamb over the top of it
a cumin some sumac things like that but
a zatar if you have it when it comes out
you put dots of
cream cheese on top of it or it can work
with feta if you want to so there's so
many different ways you can do it
without having to go through the whole
routine of
i'm really bored of making sourdough
loaves now i've made 12 bigger than my
head i don't want to do any more the
base is everything and you can taste the
sour in the base
you can taste that sourdough pizza for
sure
[Music]